плани професор і коли ви висував і
україну раніше ще до початку нинішню
декомунізації че позначала ви потреба в
ліквідації радянської символіки чиба чан
і пам'ятники таки потрібно було 2 month
ago ти родзинки грибів у ніцці той же не
став звичайним у всіх місцях до судів стояв
і пам'ятника і он і практично bleach ost
іншу знаємо його ландшафту
олег червоний занепалої сусідка мене геть і
стала їх ними епіцентрами
наприклад у харкові пам'ятник леніну
став місяцем за зустрічі антимайдану
пам'ятник шевченку
все за кілька 100 метрів став місяцем
за зустрічі активістів майдану
таким чином тип пам'ятники став та
політично зарядженими
як місяця зу зустрічі я до чого зайві
місця через ніч з ніг штату європейських
стандартів європейської практики
декомунізації та чиюсь видають
українські підходи про декомунізацію
європейським у яблуні їм я каюсь
універсального рішення як підходила
будете конче
нами пам'ятають навісне в Європі багата
гранний до світла співає дружина з фсб
очищену диктатуру ces тусується на лише
р океанської зони
ти так уже тусується і західноєвропейською
зони можна задати кращому зв'язку режим
Франко
з 1000 ми завидних у громадян скіфи не
і тисячам і біженцям в іспанії душі
пізду пішов і ось так і говорить і проти
диктатуру в затишних місцях всі стоять
пам'ятники франку
позбавлені не вийшло ексгумація братських
могил
великих був епоху вони жертви громадян
поточними топ то європейський до світліше
алаева в тіла не в кожному а кримом на жаль
катування дуже різьблене легше жери ти про
спільна в Європі thats із забезпечення
відкритості
той доступу ду архіві а моя but i чоловік
злим щоб ми не знав з опитування ще
залишилося, а це вже ураганський годинник
чим годинник нацизму обидва франки і самий вид
крики архіві україна
вибух було дуже важливо нині все
хтось стежу радіанську історію їдуть до
києва там обліком можна протирати в
архівах у Москві
у дружини можна там закрито ви suisse чиї
може і сказати ще я побожним виходить
через європейський підхід він загинув
solve babysitter простежується
тенденція то певна вона bespeco в
український законотворчий ок
позначаємо про підлогову стаєш
інституту національної пам'яті батька
інституту свою чергу
хлопець суспільно до зайвих архів кгб
шуму владний вин у означає наукою а
че пропагандою у ціни завдання державної
інституті а завдання історики другому
влади в тему галявини безпосередньо на
bespeco авторитарного регулювання того
я по разу не ти і раз побачити
українську історію це дуже погано
віджати україна визнала таку різьблену
історію заради омський терор сталінський
терор у лоб кістки
покупцю нацистську негайну в
порядку води так і складні минуло не
можеш дружини інститут національної пам'яті
там вже з право граматика стилі вежа
радіо газет академічному інституті
лінзу бачиш нічого здалася від уже
прекра історія в тему контексті група
європейських там риканських істориків
викликало протест проти його законодавства
середніх black майже лиж та проукраїнські
люди такі захищають на важливість
україни його чуючи за 1000 он і на полі
Гана тому ще дозволить і критику
вати український націоналізм цех лояльних
до україни викравши засудила як
антиукраїнських їм погладжував і не дати
доступ до архіву і пізніше єсс-но вертолом
легітимний рук до радянізації стати
декомунізації
алое також недобрий тенденції і можна
посміхатися подітися себе на 1000
українська форматі пензель ось цю статтю
сильну то курну що плитки ну ти їх
любиш глюк зі струн goes up тобі
у крим їхніх населених пунктах України
спав ахкають протести проти
перейменування засіки у кіровограді
я кола вдома і на цілі гуго ти їх тексти
з хилиш ще у рішенні небули
нав'язаним з гри в авральному порядку
і наші з матами
фатальні на зливки треба перрі конова
ти місяців і громади ви рубля ти влада
не д-р наприклад узо поріччя стоїть
пам'ятник леніну в україні їхніх тисяч ще я
абсолютним анахронізмом все ж таки труби
вимити сито граматики та активісти за
парижі я геть і просто пов'язала лінину
жовто-синій шалог та й ось такі спосіб
знаєш кодова декомунізація че до
Радянізації владне нормальні не
драматичний процес яким жінкам вигляду
зовсім screen у польші синій не мішені та
чехословаки нетанії
акиншин умма навідується у формі су
спину you дискусії в горні ток-шоу чин
обв'язування рішення я можу [ __ ] навчаю в
україні баталії ще думаю нову до зростання
та c
для політичної як би сів диня і
дитинча про декомунізацію і до
радизації dc праві рішення довідкових
проблем засіки
про деолігархізацію колиму злодієм а
просто гуманізацію то розуміємо api
цінність мінуси молимо про видно в небі дно
син для покласти правоту свобода людей
немає за такі види але син можна ви вирішать і
вже кулі такої історії чечні проблеми а
за розпаду куди складати а вираз
всю історію викрутити іспити до ви
вирішення справ dino хворих проблем я до
вам за честю досвіду не через радіанс
з тест вам нібито воду тис лелека злодієм і
соцреалізму з бригад і вусачі на спокої
у сосни чого ти вергун і снуд венге
так злить ворота простер для протирання c
гарною
вони продавлювати і рішення насельниць
шляхом страху комунізму продажів бартек 10
лити і в тому кримінально вигляд minisd вигляд
стояв до нацизму в демедж і не столітті і
був хлопець вона коротким створі волосся і
буду волос рис не мови
а ось декади просто фантастично ми
закохані та стрибала з харкер
хто на губу харкові таємницею зрозуміло
на історію європейської архітектури
1020 це 30 руки з вали в харкові
для мене найкраща ще я у європейській
архітектурі
люстру voted шейдеман платиться за раз
дихати через тисячу c буду вали
уральський годинник і повну дурницю і всім
ранок батова ти грішиш увіть застукали
принизив на зайві вологи і заражають йому
зайчики українському метрополітені це
монумента бочки з образом а ти в мені я
ubimouss man in key літри я був на
виставці цих мозаїк про крим з
випорожнення ви товару мистецтва inci
фотореалістичний кітч ітр обама ти можна
весь процес фаворити
а зараз тусується батьківщини матері той
їм хто перебуваючи убори заспівав її деу місця
на багата більше зауважують колосальних
і мер не psy вдих марат шасі з будова
не в кращих намірах до нього за ним з
якоюсь вона вище за батьківщину мати і
монастирі
києво-печерська лавра вчить його важливо те
не повтор не об'єкти з руїн овали
силует дніпровських спилил
через ці 2 до його топпер доміну йти
побачити чи не будемо ще по стала
віддаленості та 0 обидві руки на нтс 10
iphone все здається до заженуть європейський
до свята декомунізації
на прокладку барні нічиї та варшаві я
щиро форум
так подібний доз види
берліні woola комісія я побачила
харчуванням і переманювання у вулицях mist та
так далі також мало місця дискусія як
на мене в аномалів spokane відривати з
душем георгій димітрів та клару цеткін
bull і викури на ньому можна з добрих алі
не варто 100 перукою нових причин
відомий пам'ятник леніну зараз фільму
в
buy ленін та демонтувала за розвиток
знову викопала як на мене найкращий
рішення у варшаві та другому центрі місця
я площі філь від там стоїть бутони у
50-ти палац культури удар біля ніг сталіна
член вибухового не варшаві сіток
сталінському моментально будова
потурання реня
так би молодий і новий центр післявоєнної
варшави харчування стояв підноситься вчора
бути з тим символом
радіанс кого сталінського розуміння
більше і даси з але я дискусія адже ви
міг суміші не до косметична перегудова
це давидова і рішення поки що щіток і
цілительський platts обставили але видимих
маракасами
з бетону та скла коли ви приїдете до
варшави у вас складається вираз
рахунок downtown у франкфурті з
монументальні палати потовщені березня
самі з буду не класичні немає вже
прекрасний народ шосе і м'язи не прямо
мандрівниками хмара джосеф мета жест по ну а
не відривати силоміць інші значення
інтегральний від товщини і c стала одним
з найпопулярніших місць для проведення
конференцій та інших масових заходів він
ж slide давати йому жив або впорайтеся та
інтелекту місяців та громади
місця тому що vin коди багатший ніж
кейс державний орган у чому можеш сісти
надувати давид давати і накази я
затягну пніпу поспішають так і не буде
знайдено ідею яко
образливої ​​теми вона роз'їздами be so good
fun and professor однаковим за інтерв'ю